DesignX is an accelerator and
educational program that's focused on
design and the built environment.
The program allows students to take
what they are creating here at MIT— in
studios, in classes, ideas they may have
developed on their own—and to use those
and develop those while they're in
school to launch them into their
professional careers or to new businesses.
DesignX is looking not first
at the business but but really at the
problem and the design solution for it.
Students here don't shy away from those
and that's what I'm really excited about:
is giving them the tools to address those challenges.
We sense how spaces are used.
The developers have the means and capacity to do this today.
We're bringing these opportunities to the masses, to our members.
At this point we're envisioning it as a set of computer science materials.
Once you're in the program, there's a business workshop
and a full-on accelerator studio.
Where they work on their ideas
and turn them into marketable products or processes.
You're receiving mentorship from
professionals, from business people, from industry experts.
The research that we do at DesignX
is immediately being fed
back into the educational platform.
We're finding gaps
in the existing organizational structure
to identify where should our new organizations
head in the direction towards.
With our partners in industry this could be
a chance to take an idea and actually deploy it,
to test it in a real-life setting.
We'll have a two-way flow of information:
to understand the challenges from the real world
and bring those into DesignX,
and to take the products and the solutions
that we're developing here
and push them out into the world.
They're transforming cities.
They are developing new approaches
to design and ways for people to live.
This is a school that is based on creativity
and interaction with communities
and making life better for people.
That's the whole mission of the school.